hi I'm Erik Bosse so now that Black
Panther is in theaters close followers
of Marvel Cinematic Universe we're left
with a big mystery where the hell is the
final Infinity stone that's right even a
movie as thrilling as Black Panther
can't be satisfying enough for us we
need answers plum John McLean is coming
people he wants those precious little
jams and after the previous five
Infinity stones were established
throughout to the other MCU movies to
this point we just assume that Black
Panther would probably reveal the
location of the final Infinity stone the
soul stone
no no just turned out to be its own
great movie with a little care for
connecting things to the broader MCU
other than a post-credits scene
revealing Bucky was in what conduct even
though you know we already knew he was
in Wakanda
so let's speculate on where this final
infinity stone could be or what this
upcoming infinity war event is based on
the Infinity Gauntlet story arc in the
comics in that series the mad Titan
Thanos aims to assemble each of the six
infinity gems and his Infinity Gauntlet
to basically become infinity master of
the Infinity known infinity universe in
the movies these have been called the
Infinity stones the space stone the mine
stone the reality stone the Power Stone
and the time stone and the soul stone
for a detailed breakdown on what these
first five can do and where they
currently are go check out Sam bashers
Infinity stones video on this channel
it's super informative and oh so
charming now it's not clear on what
these soul stone powers will be in the
movies but in the comics the possessor
of the soul gem can control all these
souls in the universe and even connect
with the souls of the deceased so where
is this sucker we have four theories and
since we're nerds let's start with the
comics spoiler warning for the Infinity
Gauntlet comics series even though I
don't think the movies will go exactly
in this direction one of the key heroes
to lead to Thanos's defeats is a
character named Adam warlock he is a
genetically perfect super bean also
known as him a deity figure who ends up
getting control of the gauntlet from
Thanos and nobly agreeing to divide the
gems among worthy possessors lame Adam
warlock is known for having the soul
stone embedded in his forehead a lot
like vision in the movie sue has the
mind stone in his forehead
many fans assumed Marvel Studios was
adapting that detail from Adam warlock
into visions origin but then
at the end of guardians of the galaxy
part two a post-credits scene revealed
aisha fuming and defeats than planning
her next move to destroy the guardians
within the creation and a new boyfriend
I think I shall call him madam
oh it looks like Adam warlock is planned
to join the MCU maybe he will have the
soul stone with him like he does in the
comics now if that could be the case I
don't think we would see the soul stone
right away in the first infinity war
movie considering we haven't really met
Adam warlock yet we know really nothing
about his movie adaptation rather I
think it would be more likely that he
would come into play in guardians of
galaxy part 3 whenever that comes out at
Marvel phase or or heat delivered by the
way one of Sam's theories is that we
won't even see the soul stone until the
second infinity war movie and I think
that's possible along with the theory
that
Pano's might already have the soul stone
but Sam brought up another idea that
brings us to our second theory the soul
stone is in Wakanda of course now that
we've seen Black Panther that Syria
seems to be a bit debunked which is
surprising considering a big part of
Black Panther was communing with the
deceased souls in the ancestral plane a
soul plane if you will oh wait yeah
that's a Ardea thing a wonderful thing
however her the footage we've seen so
far from Avengers infinity war features
a massive battle between Thanos is out
writers and the forces of all conduct so
danus must want something from what
Conda right so I don't think we should
rule this place out just because we
didn't see the soul stone in Black
Panther doesn't mean it wasn't there and
he was just hiding in plain sight for
example the big freakin chunk of
vibranium that crashed into the place
enriching the soil and producing a
heart-shaped herb that gives people soul
powers yes maybe at the heart of this
mountain of vibranium mined by the
wakandans is a tiny tiny orange little
gem that could neatly fit on the fun
part of thanasis gauntlet I know what
you're gonna say the vibranium meteorite
in those opening shots had a bluish
blackish color in the heart-shaped herb
it's purple and although Marvel seems to
be swapping around the colors of the
stones in the movies and the Jinzo
comics this six stones as we saw them in
the collectors explanation and guardians
of the galaxy depicted the remaining
soul stone as orange but that doesn't
mean that when and yes it's a win not an
if because my imagination always assumes
the worst Thanos level
Mount Pechanga and shatters the
vibranium Mound a little nugget at its
core couldn't be orange or maybe we
shouldn't worry so much or the colors
and instead anticipate a sick soul stone
with a nice sleek black color I'm told
black is a new orange however if the
soul stone does indeed end up being in
Wakanda I guess that would be a little
convenient right like in all the realms
and all the galaxies of the six building
blocks making up the universe's source
code three of them would be on this one
pale blue dot also the stone ended up
being in Wakanda would contradict what
black panther director Ryan Coogler said
recently in an interview that vibranium
itself is enough of a MacGuffin and it
wouldn't feel right to complicate it
with another layer of importance saying
Marvel wasn't interested in doing that
either
then again merging MacGuffins is exactly
what they did with the eye of agamotto
and the time stone so they might do it
again but if we're even willing to
believe that the soul stone could be
hide in plain sight it's worth
revisiting another theory of its
possible location Heimdall from the Thor
movies leading up to Thor Ragnarok one
super popular theory was that Heimdall
who can see all the souls in the
universe wherever they are possesses the
soul stone after all his eyes are a
similar orange colour to what we expect
the soul stone to be maybe the stone is
just like bobbing around in his brain
now when the soul stone didn't show up
in Ragnarok many of us tossed out that
theory but who knows maybe like Ryan
Coogler Taika Waititi didn't want his
movie to focus too much on setting up
details for the future infinity war
event leaving that for a Kevin Feige and
the Russo brothers to figure out later
that could be why thor ragnarok which i
thought was super fun included this kind
of unnecessary Heimdall subplot that
kept cutting back to him on Asgard maybe
was just to remind him that he's still
part of the Cinematic Universe and he
might have some greater importance later
I'm just saying it's a possibility that
infinity door will open with you know
professor plum there cruelly popping off
into Silva's head to scoop out the soul
stone like the innards of a pumpkin
maybe not that graph but I'm seeing one
other possible hiding place of the soul
stone and the current MCU that could
give some broader significance to part
of the cinematic world that seems like
it's pretty disconnected from the main
narrative ant-man the soul stuff is
inside
Tank Engine I mean have you really
looked actually what is in there is it
is it brains or like a a weird slug
thing now of course I'm referring to the
quantum realm ant-man's exponential
shrinking down beyond the subatomic
levels opened up the biggest mystery
from the first movie and honestly what
I'm most excited to see from the
upcoming ant-man in the wasp what
exactly is the quantum realm
what did Janet Van Dyne being played
here by Michelle Pfeiffer experienced in
the time she spent there will it be
anything like the Microverse in the
Marvel Comics which is known to contain
entire subatomic planets and societies
of life-forms I think the quantum realm
could be a really interesting source of
the soulstone and a way to make Ant Man
actually important to the war against
Thanos other than you know shrinking
down crawling up his ass and so if by
chance the soulstone still doesn't show
up in the first infinity war movie this
may and Marvel ends up making it more
important to the second part of the
story I'm just saying don't count out
the quantum realm guys big things can
come in small whatever you get it where
do you think the final Infinity stone
could be which of these four seem like
the most likely to you were in my
overlooking someplace comment with your
thoughts down below and tweet me
directly at EA boss or follow new rock
stars on twitter at new rock stars for
updates on their videos and of course
subscribe to new rock stars video dives
into everything marble everything you
missed on black panther and other
theories on the upcoming and ventures
affinity war and guerrilla kids want to
help us grow and contribute to the
channel on patreon a big thanks to all
of our donors especially nephew solve us
thanks for watching bye